another question yeah um just when you
were uh early when you were talking
about the sensing oh where what are your
thoughts on the breathing during the
um well doing each other techniques but
also on the book arrival as well yeah
that's a good question isn't it
is our breathing is our breathing
correct or not what the biggest problem
is
we don't realize when we're holding our
breath
what a big problem I've got with uh
iwama students is they go they
I'm going why are they key on after it's
a little bit like saying I need that
coal shoveling over here so you go over
there and you go oh go get a shelf
alumni it's like I need the breath
what what's the oh since the um
what's the old Scentsy videos
hey I
you need the breath to do the technique
oh come on
if I Kia afterwards
sorry
hey
this is not so I don't know why they do
it they all say to me oh we were taught
that in Iran and I go you know I don't
like it I've always been a rebel I
always been an individual if I'm going
to be
hey
that's when I need the breath when I
need it
why would I
look you can do without breath
you can do it without breath but then
that's you're going into mind power
you're going into telepathy
you're going into mind power
why is he falling down he doesn't know
what I'm doing is I'm I've already
focused on him like I'll focus on you so
if I focus on you but I can still focus
on him so now I've got two I've got
Focus I focus on Jenny so now I've got
three I can focus on Dominique's I've
got four so you're all now plugged into
me
so any car I'll try and explain this
when he comes I don't just softly go
over here and go
oh I don't know nothing happening if I
go
I had to get in his head and sense
him
it's almost like I had to go
this is just this is just my this is
just my hand you know but if I go with
my mind
it's almost like you're pushing air
that's the only way I could describe it
to you it's like I'm pushing air and if
you do this with your hands you can
actually feel what I mean about
condensing air
so you know you can try it by all means
you know I don't always talk about this
stuff sometimes I do but if you can feel
this condensing of air between your two
hands
is it condensed in air or is it
condensing your energy
so when I do this it's a measured point
over him and it's a measured point I
mustn't go further or else it will
the space will be too great
too complicated really isn't it
but uh
that's when you see oh you see how are
you going to learn that you've got to
watch how Scentsy and you've got to try
and get inside him you're watching a
film and you've got to go what's he
doing how is it how is he how's that
sense he'd been able to do that throw
them down you know how has those scents
have been able to go
how can he control that how can you get
them
how can he make that you know this big
strong man how can he make him just fall
down like that the physical side
we've got a connection but mentally
essentially here look
so that's the mental and physical
so what I've done over the years I've
tried to get inside what I think our
sense is doing and then I've thought
about ah but he used to sit a lot and do
meditation didn't he and I don't believe
in religion so I'm not going to go down
that track but I'm going to try and do
as many things as he'd done so he would
sit and I know that as we all sit if you
just sit there and go what am I supposed
to think about you're thinking too hard
if you go
I'm just going to breathe out and try
and think of nothing
or I think something's coming in now
thank you I just want to be think of
nothing
that space
is what I obtain before I do what I just
shown you
I have a space I have I obtain a space
of nothingness only calmness and peace
when you do that correctly you're more
powerful than ever
all right so use it as an action
but it can be a
there's this one
you take it
foreign
so what I'm doing is perhaps different
to what you're doing but if you do the
mechanical things follow your own
beliefs follow your own paths at the end
of it well hopefully it's not my end yet
but when you get down get into my line
you'll know whether your path worked out
right or not
you can't you know I don't believe in
all that crap you know if that's where
you want to believe don't want to
believe in it you might be better I
could earn anybody but I remember I
remember somebody saying many years ago
when he to hero was a young man
um
where I think I don't know if he said it
but he said we're all waiting for
another oh Scentsy